il est 6 heures jours de collecte des
matières recyclables à 500 avance michel
patoine parcourent les rues depuis
plusieurs heures déjà à la recherche de
contenants consignés
ici le rôle du trou c'est heureux à la
suite d'une maladie qui lui a fait
perdre son emploi
michel est devenu sans abri j'avais le
choix me retrouver sur le social ou
faire feu il a donc opté pour la récolte
des canettes et des bouteilles jetés à
la rue moi l'année longue marche
je vis avec ça il fait en moyenne entre
20 et 50 dollars par jour il se prétend
pandémique a été bénéfique
le maximum que remonter puissant
d'europe en inde au début de la crise
les détaillants ont refusé les
contenants consignés pour assurer la
sécurité de leurs employés
ils n'ont repris du service à montréal
qu'à partir du 22 juin ce qui a laissé
le champ libre à l'organisme l'aco
appelé valoriste qui achètent les
contenants des ramasseurs comme une
chaîne on faisait des schistes des fous
dans une journée
cette entreprise d'économie sociale
dessert une population parfois marginal
moins tolérées par les détaillants quand
tu commences à mettre 1000 à 2000 qu on
a conscience dans une machine comme ça
selon il vole traité comme un être
humain avec un mot et rêvent pas ça sera
plus un une poubelle qui rend dans un
litre frites pour cet expert des
matières résiduelles
l'apport de ces valoriste étaient des
niable on tente désespérément depuis des
dizaines d'années de jeter moins deux
choses à la fois par la réduction à la
source en changer nos habitudes mais
aussi en interceptant des matériaux qui
sait garder ma technique s'en vont pas
au bon endroit
québec travaille actuellement aux
modalités de l'élargissement de la
consigne notamment bouteilles de vin et
aux contenants de lait prévue en 2022
les valoriste voudrait faire partie de
la solution que l'on voit dans d'autres
juridictions c'est plutôt apparaître
toute une série de un petit comptoir de
récupération un rêve que caressent les
valoriste